Hey guys what's up this is going to be a video
all about Hodor.
A lot of you have asked for video explaining
what's going on with his character the last
time we saw him It was very ambiguous, so
just careful for spoilers for everything this
happened through season 6 so far there is
a lot of evidence to suggest that were going
to see him again, and there's a number of
different ways the show could accomplish that
based on bran's abilities and a couple of
key scenes that I'll explain, there is a new
round of the game of thrones giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's for
one of the enhanced editions of the books.
There are two big ways the show could bring
him back.
One is a wight, which would be horrifying
and 2, in another bran flashback.
So let's start with the really cool one first
Hodor as a wight, so a lot of you have asked
what happened to Hodor after he held the door
for Bran and Meera so that they could escape.
So there couple key scenes that sort of explain
what's going on and why he might come back
as a white and not white walkers slightly
different.
He might come back as a white Walker pending
the engines explanation which is another key
scene when he explained how he was slowly
being turned into another white Walker himself.
So at the end of episode five.
We get to explainer for his name that's the
big reveal, hold the door bran had simultaneously
skin shifted into Hodor and was controlling
him to hold the door while he was also in
the past watching what was happening at winter
fell he doesn't fully understand how his magic
works yet so it creates this crazy feedback
loop that short-circuits some of the language
centers of Hodor's brain.
The way they presented Hodor in the early
seasons is that he's simpleminded, but you
learn that he does understand everyone he
just the speed centers of his brain that have
been affected.
So in this moment, he sort of gets subconsciously
stuck on this future moment he probably never
fully understood what was going on till he
was in that moment himself will will will
photo but the other big revelation that we
gun in the last season is that the others
or the white walkers have you want to call
them there only cold white walkers on the
TV show in the books they're called others.
They have an intelligence of their own they're
not just mindless drones the night King is
probably the most powerful person on the planet
next to bran right now.
So he wants to swell his rings, but typically
dead people are raised as whites not as white
walkers.
So there really fuzzy on the rules for how
you create a white Walker we do know that
only the night King can create new white walkers
the white walkers themselves can raise whites
one at a time.
But the night King can raise them all at once
so very different power levels, but a lot
of it just depends on what their plan is for
any given person.
So the reason that the night King probably
wanted to turn Benjen and into another white
Walker is because of his skills and his knowledge.
So once you become a white Walker.
You're basically a thrall of the night King.
You do have like your own intelligence and
your own agency, but you're bound to him.
So whoever you were before, just completely
disappears had Benjen and been fully turned
he would've killed Brandon Mira on the spot
but also to Jon right decision Felicity and
the Wolf is arranging they been to the north.
The founders light will stop me and that the
sort of Irish that to Joseph some soap to
focus much of textiles have the same way them.
It will cushion the first lease show yourself
trying the shot of Dragon glass Constantine
1/2 but what about Hodor it would be a crazy
WTF to see him come back in a crowd shot as
a white Walker or as a wight which one would
just depend on whether or not you believe
that he died in that moment whether he was
ripped to shreds or not, because they can
animate whites that are basically just skeletons
this Ray Harryhausen looking wight here is
almost full skeleton from the end of season
for, so they're pretty good.
Hodor is not dead in the truest sense of the
work and when people asked George RR Martin
about it because Dan and Dave this Hodor twist
from him.
He said have you seen a body you know may
be odors not that he's very ambiguous about
stuff like that.
So you just left to wonder.
So if there is a chance that he's alive he's
probably still alive but not in the way that
you would expect because while Benjen and
had the children of the forest to save him
from being turned into a white Walker Hodor
does not have that he has an army of whites
that are trying to get through that door they
were really clear about it either, but the
actor who plays bran was mostly responding
to the Hodor twist like nice one bran-new
piece of this all in motion kill the three
eyed Raven and got Hodor killed to but the
even bigger implication is that the children
of the forest have died off.
Now that those were like the final surviving
members of their race, now part of the reason
I think they're being so ambiguous is because
they want bran to be on his own.
He says to Benjen and you know I don't understand
my powers.
I didn't get the full explainer from the three
eyed Raven before he uploaded all of his knowledge
into my mind which is basically what was happening.
He was unlocking some of brands abilities
but at the same time uploading all this knowledge
that he'd accumulated.
So if you want to believe that Hodor is coming
back as a white or even a white Walker, although
I think it be more likely that he would be
a white he would have to be some moment, that
they would save for the bran character just
because it be more meaningful that way in
seeing twisted Hodor and being confronted
with his failure.
So there are number of reasons why you could
argue that they will not bring Hodor back
is a white.
So typically the big twist on the TV show
have some deeper meaning to the story like
the big twist about white walkers being the
creation of the children of the forest when
they were fighting the first men in their
big war for west roast their whole line of
logic is that they were losing and then they
needed a weapon of mass destruction to stop
the first men from completely destroying their
race, but in doing so they lost control of
their own creation and now they threatened
everyone so it's a big WTF twist but it makes
sense from a narrative perspective you create
that thing that will eventually destroy you.
So whoever you're fighting the war against
isn't your greatest enemy you are your own
greatest enemy or your failings or your hubris
or your weaknesses, it's the same thing with
Cersei Cersei's greatest enemy isn't the faith
of the seven or wasn't the faith of the seven
because she took care of them at the end of
the season it's really herself.
She will do something that will lead to her
own downfall in the way that the children
of the forest.
It.
So I'm less likely to back some big WTF twist
theory unless it's in service of wrapping
up a really awesome plot line like the idea
that Arya would cross Cersei's name offer
list while at the same time fulfilling the
prophecy of the Valonqar by wearing Jamie's
face to read like a crazy WTF twist theory,
but it helps.
So up a lot of the logic in the books.
Whether or not the TV show decides to go that
route, so let me know.
Do you think that Hodor is going to come back
as a white in the future season whether it's
in the books or on the TV show is totally
possible if you just go based on the logic
of what they presented.
So far he would have to be a white but it
just depends on what types of scenes they
want to do with white walkers in season seven,
but in related news, I know a lot of you are
asking about a video ranking the characters
based on their magic abilities so I'll be
doing a video for that this week if you free
to leave other suggestions for game of thrones
videos you guys want me to do on the channel
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my Arya Stark Valonquar video
and you can click here to learn how Marvel
is getting ready for a really big reboot in
the next couple of years.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!